soak in that moment of Royal Fab Four
from September because we probably won't
see that happen ever again welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight listen
the backlash from Harry and Megan's
docu-series is coming in from all sides
everybody has an opinion and now shock
jock Howard Stern has decided to weigh
in
they come off like such whiny it's like
the Kardashians except boring companies
do you know how to curtsy right
and I just thought it was a joke it
seems so hypocritical you want to be
left alone but then you sell a special
on Netflix when those two start whining
about
and they don't like me I think I've
heard the story when Oprah interviewed
you the first time I found it troubling
Howard held nothing back but is his
nasty review part of a Harry and Megan
backlash you know Steve
Harry and Megan
watch anyway
the doc's audience score on Rotten
Tomatoes is an incredibly low 11 and
even the couple seems to be distancing
themselves from the project which was
part of a reported 100 million dollar
deal Harry and Megan aren't listed as
producers on the dock and they
reportedly wanted the show pushed back
until next year Megan also made it a
point to mention quote we're trusting
our story to someone else and that means
it will go through their lens over in
the UK William Kate just released this
family photo for the holidays but the
Royal Buzz is all about King Charles's
coronation set for May will Harry and
Megan be there don't hold your breath
here's why three more episodes of their
controversial Netflix doc drop tomorrow
at midnight we're happy to lie to
protect my brother and Harry's got a
potentially explosive new Memoir out
next month another Factor the date of
the coronation May 6th the date does
fall on Archie's fourth birthday a happy
coincidence I'm told but of course it
will be down to the sussexes to make the
ultimate decision as to whether they're
going to come over for King Charles's
coronation
foreign